aujourd'hui nous allons tester le nom de
chaque ou un art martial d'origine
japonaise qui a puisé à son énergie dans
les paysans du pays
alors nous sommes à vos repas pour
tester cette discipline oliva
[Musique]
bonjour taheri jour alors que kelly
programme aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on va vous enseignez du
choco de combat vous faire une
initiation une choucroute murs du
château de combat c'est pas trop
difficile
non non c'est très simple vous inquiétez
pas j'ai à prendre dès le premier cours
et vous serez opérationnels pour faire
des promos bon allez c'est parti
ok alors taillerie c'est quoi le premier
exercice
alors on va vous montrer la première
attaque première attaque c'est parti
première attaque où nichent en coûte
combat où on se met en garde à l'épaule
mais comme ça j'essaie de comprendre un
petit peu voilà voilà
hélas ce qu'on va faire on va frapper en
en remontant le bras bouche et on peut
continuer de l'autre côté frais et les
bus et de frapper l'adversaire partie
celle attaques de base la salle de base
et robert a fallu quand même essayer de
faire honneur à cette première attaque
s'est pas trop trop difficile on va voir
s'il va se compliquer favre a une bonne
coordination une bonne coordination
l'un des principal atout du choc combat
c'est qu'on travaille le bras droit et
bras gauche
du coup on travaille la coordination
globale il faut placer sans combat après
on va partir au combat je faisais
important donc les frappes du corps
jusqu'aux pieds c'est un point et la
frappe à la tête ces deux points c'est
pourtant bien les deux profs par
habitant voilà
[Musique]
3 pourquoi ne pas
thomas
[Musique]
si c'est interdit c1 perdue
voilà les trois mots trois corps pour
moi c'est un arrachement
[Musique]
bon c'est fini allez comme sa chasse
pour ses nus merci beaucoup merci au
revoir au revoir
[Musique]